foreign
[Music]
people liked it a lot you know my people
read astrophysicists that were all about
Fusion just want you to know that yes
yes you guys you really stick together
I'm sorry that was not that was that was
awful
so yeah the
just so you know where we're coming from
every single star
in the universe that is sort of alive
alive in a stellar sense is undergoing
thermonuclear fusion and that whole word
that you can parse it Thermo is heat
that nuclear is the nucleus and fusion
is bringing together of of nuclei and it
happens that when you bring in the
quantum physics and the into the
periodic table of elements
and you slam these nuclei together you
make heavier nuclei that are missing
some Mass
an atomic Moss Pit and the mass has
become energy right so here's what's
here's what's interesting so cool here's
what's interesting yeah just just I
think it's interesting but you you and
the viewers listeners will be the judge
of this very much you've heard you've
heard of nuclear fission of course
this is where you take a big atom such
as uranium or plutonium as we've done in
the past those are big atoms all right
92
94 protons crammed into its nucleus okay
and that's like the opposite of hydrogen
which has one proton in its nucleus
right so the hydrogen we use for fusion
and make heavier elements and fission we
take the big elements and split them
apart so you split them apart you get
other elements when you add up their
mass is less
and you get energy from that and this is
the foundations of the the nuclear
fission Arsenal the bombs used in the
second world war right were fission
bombs okay so now watch
well if splitting it Adam
gets you splitting heavy atoms gets you
energy
infusing light atoms gets you energy
right
well then what's going on is there some
point
in the middle
right where does it know if you split it
or fuse it what can happen so here's
here's what's going on as you fuse atoms
you get less and less energy out from
the fusion
as the atoms get bigger as you split
atoms
you get less and less energy out for
having split them okay
okay gotcha all right all right so it
turns out there is a place in the
periodic table of elements
where that element
if you split it
it absorbs energy
and if you fuse it
it absorbs energy oh
so you can't Fizz past it
and still expect to make energy and you
can't fuse past it
the buck stops there
wow and that element
is iron
iron period on the periodic table of
elements see if this were a Marvel movie
we would call it absorption or something
like that
we must get the element absorption
so that we can stop this reaction and
save the universe yes it would stop all
freaking reactions correct correct you
cannot Fizz iron you cannot fuse iron
okay so this effort to undergo nuclear
fission technical nuclear fusion has a
stopping point all right so stars are
born with hydrogen and helium and they
start fusing and they work their way up
the periodic table in Mass okay so the
sun has other stars we'll do they start
in hydrogen they make helium right right
and then they take three helium atoms
bring them together and you get oh well
let's figure it out uh helium has two
protons okay so he takes three of those
atoms how many protons you have three
okay
it'll tell me I went to Public Schools I
don't know
okay by the way I went to public school
K through 12. so
um so two two and two now you have six
protons you go check the periodic table
of elements who has six protons carbon
does aha okay so uh we go from hydrogen
to helium the carbon in there there are
other Pathways that get other elements
but these are the primary ones okay you
get the carbon and you get nitrogen
oxygen and so there's a there are these
Fusion Pathways that work their way up
the periodic table and at each step the
sun is making energy right okay so the
sun can hold itself up against
gravitational collapse gotcha because it
wants to collect this gravity it's a let
me make this sucker as small as possible
but the fusion is saying no you're not
no you're not no you're not right I'm
preventing that so there's pressure
without and pressure within correct so
the pressure pushing out is the fusion
actually propping up the sun in its size
and creating perfect perfect phrase
propping up the sun that's exactly what
it's doing wow
now there are people who misinterpret
this because we say it is balanced right
okay you know the star is about the sun
is balanced because it's not shrinking
and it's not expanding right okay here's
an interesting fact
it is balanced
as a ball would be at the bottom of a
hill between two Hills not balanced as
it would be at the top of a hill right
these are two different kinds of balance
absolutely at the top of the hill you
can just barely balance it and put it in
what we call equilibrium but it's an
unstable equilibrium that's an official
term I love it unstable because if you
just breathe on the marble it'll fall
down the hill right right okay all right
now the ball at the bottom of the
between two hills and a trough is also a
an equilibrium but it's a stable
equilibrium if you blow on it it'll go
up the side and come right back down to
where it was right stars are not in a
delicate balance they're in a stable
balance okay so watch what happens if
you compress the star
the star gets hotter
creates more energy and pumps itself
back up oh
if you figure if you somehow manage to
Puff it up that releases the pressure on
the inside the nuclear fuel uh energy
rate drops and then it shrinks back down
again look at that
it's it's there it is stable equilibrium
that's wonderful it's a totally
wonderful thing especially if you have
long-term civilizations that you want to
sort of yeah uh if you if you're gonna
if you're going to be a civilization
that is smart enough
to use that power and energy then you
have a stable source of power that is
always working and you don't have to
worry about it being unstable because
it's in a state of stable equilibrium
but you know that's kind of I mean who
could ever do that that's ridiculous yet
another public service announcement from
Chuck Nice okay all right so Watch What
Happens so there's the star and it is
and there are more details that we have
time to get into here but the star is
cranking its way up the periodic table
of elements and each of these new
elements creates an onion skin layer in
the center of the star so there's
um the outer layer has the hydrogen and
helium and carbon and because the sun is
only hottest at the center right and it
has to be really hot to fuse the bigger
elements because I need more energy more
temperature higher speed speeds to fuse
helium than I did hydrogen because
helium has two protons and two protons
there's more resistive Force there than
one proton and one proton if I want to
fuse carbon I got six protons and six so
it is that the the center of the star it
gets hotter and hotter and hotter to in
order to make this happen okay wow I run
out of let's go back I run out of
hydrogen in my core because I made it
all into helium right okay I'm not hot
enough to fuse helium I'm not so how do
I ever end up using helium I ran out of
energy what does the star do the star
says gravity is the time for Gravity to
win and it the core collapses right
increasing the pressure increasing the
temperature until helium kicks in
look at that then helium ignites
stabilizing the star once again
you run out of helium in the core and
carbon sitting around doing nothing okay
time for the star to collapse gravity
says time for us to win again carbon
says not so fast you've now raised my
temperature so that I confuse
and so at stopping the further collapse
okay this is this is the this is the the
dance yeah that stars do with the
thermonuclear Fusion in their core so
now watch okay here's the fun part
I now get to iron
in the core and the star says we've been
down that road before right right now
right now you're not giving us energy
let's collapse right under our own
weight increase the temperature then
you'll give us energy and then you will
fuse but you won't use iron sis and
pulls up its mask and says it's me
absorption
so the star collapses ready to for iron
to give us new energy and iron says no I
absorb energy to fuse uh-oh and so now
the star which is in the business of
making energy
has a fuel source in the center that is
only absorbing energy so the star
collapses some more and iron says I will
take anything you give me and any
heavier element is going to absorb it as
well
and so the star undergoes a catastrophic
collapse
catastruct within hours this is a star
that's been alive for millions of years
millions of years and within a matter of
hours
it's a catastrophic collapse
and in that collapse the temperature
goes to
astronomically high temperatures and
here you have this ball of
astronomically high temperatures in the
collapse and it only knows one thing to
do at that point and that's explaining
it has to because it has to it can't
fuse no other choice but to explode to
explode and Chuck thus
is the appearance in the universe of a
supernova explosion better known
as a several billion year orgasm what
no those Stars don't live billions of
years they went through this fast okay
only the highest mass stars oh really
have enough have enough pressure to take
the temperature that's right the sun is
not we'll never make someone make it
because okay it's not big enough because
you need you need the pressure without
and the pressure within and it has to be
a big enough Mass not big enough in size
but it has to be a large enough mass for
that oh my God that's amazing it's
amazing so the gravity creates the
pressure and the temperature and it's
the temperature that matters because
temperature makes the particles go at
high speeds to overcome their their
repulsions so the only way you can get
to the fusion this is Fusion so that the
strong nuclear force takes over you got
to get over that hump exactly then it
sticks that's right so amazing so this
would have happened in millions of years
some will live billions some stars live
trillions these this special category of
high mass stars doesn't live very long
10 million years tops wow okay they go
to iron they create this onion layer of
elements they explode and they scatter
that enrichment across the Galaxy
allowing newly born stars in Stellar
nurseries to have planets made of
ingredients that are not just hydrogen
and helium made of planets that have
carbon nitrogen oxygen the basic
ingredients of life itself that is
that's beautiful man we're not just
poetically
Stardust
we are literally literally Stardust
Stardust correct and what I say is we're
alive in this universe yes
but think about the universe
contributing to who and what we are
through this process of thermonuclear
Fusion from hydrogen all the way up to
iron and those stars explode if those
Stars didn't explode the universe would
have all those elements locked up with
nothing to make planets and people out
of
right the fact that those stars explode
the fact that the ones that make the
elements explode allows me to tell you
that not only are we alive in this
universe
the universe is alive within us
oh that's
why do I feel like I want to take up an
offering right now
that was just gorgeous The Collection
plate is going across the plate now this
that was just beautiful man
I mean that's just wonderful man this
was figured out by four scientists A
Burbage Burbage foul Fowler and Hoyle uh
Jeff Burbridge Margaret Burbage uh
Willie Fowler and and Fred Hoyle in the
1980s
Fowler oil
um and they really deserved the Nobel
Prize for that but back then they
weren't giving them to astrophysicists
as they are today but I'm just saying
that research paper came out in 1957 I
think oh my God soon
right mid-century so this this
understanding of our place in the
universe this Cosmic perspective yes I
think of as the greatest gift that
astrophysicists have given to
civilization because it it borders on
the spiritual
for its meaning and significance and our
and our connectivity to the cosmos it
really does and it's such an elegant
picture of a closed system where dying
Stars seed the universe with life itself
and the building the ingredients for
Life the building blocks for that life
it's it's it's uh it really is just a a
lovely just almost metaphorical
depiction but it's literal depression
that's amazing that is that so I just
wanted to complete our Fusion session
together okay but see is it really
Complete because now I got to know this
because as you talk about this kind of
explosion and these uh you know elements
leaving and then going into these
Stellar nurseries and then this system
starts again now I want to know how does
the whole thing get kick-started what
happens that causes is the entire thing
to kick off in the first place that
ignites that first little spark for the
fusion
I I deeply value your insatiable
curiosity that's why I love you jack
well I appreciate it and I love you
because uh you you have answers and I
don't have to read
all right there's been another star talk
explainer fleshing out the whole story
of fusion not only on Earth but in the
universe Chuck always good to have
always a pleasure yield the grass Tyson
here keep looking up foreign